the red sox starter that's nick pivetta
2-0 era of 368.
he really has pitch well you know as a
red sox see what he can do tonight
here's ty france
fly ball gently hit verdugo slides and
makes the play who is that masked man
and takes one away from france yeah
nicely measured there by verdugo with
the slide
yeah i'm gonna say it again you know it
doesn't matter to me where they play him
left field right field
centerfield he does a great job i think
in every one of the positions
got a pretty good jump on the ball goes
into that slide got the flashy glove
i mean everything looked pretty on that
including the mask
well we go to the bottom of the first
inning tonight here at fenway and young
right-hander justin dunn on the mount
for the mariners getting ready for his
third start and his first ever
appearance against the
austin red sox enrique hernandez will
leave things off right-handed hitter
goes right back to it hernandez disposed
off good sign
that will be an important pitch for him
here this evening his average fastball
94 to 95 miles an hour but he can really
spin it brings up verdugo 288 three home
runs for alex
good count for verdugo rips into this
one
down the line that's going to tuck
underneath that padding
he's heading hard into second he wants
third base
radugo taking off and he dives in with a
triple
yeah nicely done might as well take
three
one out go for it he's sitting on a
fastball big time but he
already had a rip earlier in this count
he knows the fastball's coming and he is
ready for it
and that is straight as an arrow that
fastball right there and once it got
tied up under the fence
but dugo knew right then that he was
going to have three bases right there
once it slowed down and he couldn't see
the baseball anymore
he knew he had three without a problem
that's big in the first inning it really
is get
somebody at second base third base
trying to get that first run
trying to get ahead raphael devers will
lead things off against justin dunn
hitting 270. five home runs raphael last
night
cranked a double he's going to crack
this one deep to right you can kiss that
goodbye
off into the stands totally over the
bullpen
and the red sox grab a one-nothing lead
against don in seattle
well done boy he's giving up a couple
rockets with that fastball this ball
left the ballpark
as soon as he touched it off boy this is
the night you want to pull off your
left-handed hitter you get that gale
blowing out
toward right field this didn't need any
help this is a line
shot by rafael devas that's going to get
out of the ballpark for the home run
and that fastball that fastball is
really straight yeah i'm telling you be
careful with that cheese
number six for raphael crawford a 241
hitter pivetta
trying to make it nine up nine down to
begin to start against seattle
and a one-two see you oh
i've got to have that what and he's
walking oh
my god oh my god pivetta was almost in
the dugout
yeah he finished lasting the same way
this is a curveball this has got plate
this is backdoor gets the plate i got to
have that
2-2 and that'll be a little ground ball
scooped up by
bogarts and up and over to get him one
to nothing red sox
raffy he'll rip that one for a base hit
into the alley right fielder haniger to
cut it and it's a single for rafael
devers who's two for two boy he gets on
a roll man
and nothing but ropes everywhere what
was that paycheck was that a change
i think it was yeah it was three changes
tonight yeah
he never throws change ups no a little
bit toward the end of the bat but up the
middle for the base hit
so marwan off to first they're on the
corners now for a hunter renfrow
renfrow's got to make contact 1-2
there's a line drive base head they'll
get it done a run home
devers will score racing into third and
sliding and safely gonzales
and the red sox take a two-nothing lead
got ringing
beautiful hitting hitting right there
didn't try to get big
and just fastball stayed right on it
cross seam fastball
right down the middle you don't see
renfro do that very often you know go to
the
opposite field you he's a home run type
of guy but uh
boy he stayed on that beautifully shot
at third third
a 15 hopper to third gets gonzalez into
the bag
that's a huge hit by retro had to make
contact and he did
ringing line drive i mean that's how you
draw it up that's what you just love to
see
here's kyle lewis thank you
thank you a couple of inches struck him
out louis done one away
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
right there we
have to have that we need that ball on
the outside corner
a little frame job too lewis has got to
sit down
tramell 0-2 and oh yeah for strike three
another terrific inning walk off
the mariners suddenly have the tying run
on base and the go ahead
man at the plate hannagar at first
crawford at second two-way
2-2 to france into left field it's over
the glove
of francie corneiro crawford is coming
home
mitch haniger is steaming past third
bogart's throw to the plate
slides in safe and now france is caught
in between
after tying this game up at two no no
no more for nick pavetta as the mariners
even the score [ __ ] to start it off
bottom of the seven tied at two
and two oh he swings a high fly ball
very high
deep left backing up is tremel in a
leaping attempt by lewis he can't get it
kk hammering around
second on his way into third with a
stand up triple
now there's a ball that on a normal
night without a wind blowing out the
right field
is a home run how many triples do you
see at fenway park
that that's off the wall almost none
that ball had to be
very high for this to be three bases i
mean i thought it was gone
but with the wind blowing the way it is
tonight that's the only thing that kept
it
in the park they both jumped nobody's
backing up and that allows
tk to go all the way to third base you
almost never see
a triple off the wall at fenway park yup
that's a rarity
and leading off the inning in a tie game
trying to find a way to bring in kiki
hernandez
who led off the inning with a triple 2-2
and that one gets through all the way to
the backstop
and he's gonna score that's one way to
do it
right through the catcher torrance and
it's a 3-2 red sox lead
wow that ball should have been caught i
don't think he hit the ground caught
blocked something spinner that ball did
hit the ground that's
yeah right for the five hole it's a wild
pitch that's a long pitch
here's the stretch and now the 1-1 to
crawford
back to the mound on avino wild gets
away from denver's
hagerty's coming home and a defensive
miscue
has tied this game with three in the
eighth inning
well anavino really struggling to bunt
right back to him they had to play
he rushes to the throw throws it wide of
third
tried to throw it a hundred at him and
no chance taylor trumell gets the punt
down runner to third one out here top of
the 10th 3-3 ball game
two balls two strikes
clubbed into left field and it's over
the glove of corneiro
again evan white trots home to score
hagerty stings it to the base of the
monster he stands up at
second and with one out of the tenth
inning sam
hagerty has put the mariners in front
four to three
a little bit late on the fastball and he
finally gives him a breaking ball
right in the middle of the plate solid
line drive over cordero's head
give him 105 on the exit velocity murphy
125 with one home run
gonna crack that one down the line that
one is headed a long way
and a leaping catch what a play by
renfro
as he went sailing and took a hit up
against that side
fence and he hung on to the baseball
that is close to being a home run that
ball
slicing just enough and he sized it up
went up for the catch and
made the nice play once again renfro
coming up
with a big catch yeah that's a tough
play right there going into that wall
and you know the wind's pushing it away
from him as you can see right there
see what gives here see if haniger can
find something off the monster and left
or find something in the gap
mitch hitting 455 with runners in
scoring position this
year hanniger
out towards the triangle out towards the
short wall mitch haniger
goodbye gun home run
what a bomb in the 10th it comes with
two men
aboard and all of a sudden the mariners
have blown the doors off of fenway
it's 7-3 and 0-2 throws him another
fastball
middle middle middle 104 exit velocity
was just no matter whether he's going to
have enough to hit it out
to right center which is deep you can
see 396 is how far he hit it
and it goes into the red sox bullpen two
down here in the 10th
first endeavors soft chopper masavich
picks it up finishes this one off and
the mariners win it and 10
7-3 our final score to take game one